there's so much healing on so many
different levels happening in the world
and
one of the big ones obviously is sort of
you know how you show up for yourself in
your life and and and how that how
relationships are such a magnifying
glass for that and that's why I think
this book is so brilliant I've said to
you know talk to a few people about it
and and especially about talking to you
and they're like man I need to read that
book so
um I would imagine that on top of doing
the digital stuff you've been doing and
taking care of the land like writing a
book is like such a big project and
um okay so tell me like becoming the one
is your book tell me about it was it
intentional or did it feel like you had
to write this book like what was the
birth of this I was approached by so
many Publishers it felt like a sign for
me that it was time because I've always
wanted to write a book and I've always
been a writer
but you know when do you have the time
to write a book it's like when do you
have time to have a baby like it's the
same there's no right time you know
because you you just have to do it I
just decided okay I'm gonna do this now
if just something felt right and
I began
kind of flailing actually like I I got a
book deal and it was everything was just
so easy it almost like fell into my lap
but then I felt really confronted with
my own self-doubt and I had a lot of
resistance and
I just had to work through that for a
while
and then eventually uh Ben and I we went
to Hawaii and we stayed there for the
winter and
I remember just sitting on the couch and
being like
I can't do this I'm gonna quit I'm just
gonna give my Advance back I'm not a
writer like I was really hitting a wall
and I was crying and he just sat with me
and held space and was like okay well if
that's what you need to do and normally
he would push me but he just didn't and
then
he held space for me to do breath work
and that day
I sort of just moved through it and then
I began writing and I wrote the whole
first manuscript in four months and then
we spent about a year editing and
teasing it out and adding Essence and
all of that and so it was an interesting
Journey because I saw a block that I
didn't know was there in me and so I had
to work through that and I think that's
the beauty of doing things that
challenge us and push us push us to our
Edge
right because so often you hear like you
know you're gonna hit resistance when
they're you're on the precipice of doing
something big
um and sometimes it's so deeply
unconscious that you don't even know
it's there so I had this really cool
opportunity to to get to the edge of
quitting and then to to move forward and
to do it and and by the end of it I fell
in love with the process of writing this
book I felt like
I was deeply connecting with the people
reading it I was infusing Essence in
every page and it just felt so medicinal
to work with it
um and at the end I wrote you know an
outline for another manuscript because I
was just like this is what I love like I
want to write books this is what I want
to do healing is I've found to be very
hard and it feels it feels um there's a
lot of pain
um crying confusion
um
frustration loss all kinds of things I
wonder if we have to go through the fire
to come out the other side and so you're
talking about writing a book to help
people become the one in their
relationship to write a book and you you
had to go through your own fire to do
that and I and I really wonder are there
any shortcuts is there anywhere that we
can heal grow and evolve without having
to go through the fire well look I think
there is a bit of a yes and to that for
sure most of the time growth comes
through challenge right right and and
that's why relationships are our
greatest spiritual growth container but
they're also the hardest okay so like if
you go be a monk or a nun like it's
probably easier to become enlightened
because you don't have to deal with any
interpersonal drama right you can
get there and you can have growth
experiences and it can be gentler if you
have guidance if you have you know a
core connection to self if you have
people that you can trust who can guide
you
and sometimes it really is just going to
be hard and painful and stinky embracing
that is part of the medicine to life
remembering that it's actually not it's
not a bad thing
and it's actually even though it feels
uncomfortable to get messy you know to
lay it all out on the table
it's actually a gift because we're sort
of de-armoring in those moments we're
really letting what's true come through
and we're also letting the people
closest to us see us you know and and be
there so you know in my case like going
through the fire it was really hard but
it also created a lot of intimacy in my
partnership you know Ben had an
opportunity to support me and see a
tenderness in me you know he said I've
never seen you in self-doubt like that
like it's because it that's not really
my
default you know like I'm typically
quite confident I just trust what I'm
doing I know that I can do it I believe
in myself and so when this all came out
it was very new and he got to see this
tender part of me that he had never met
too
and so sometimes if we can just look at
it as a gift and an opportunity for
connection then it can sort of take the
pressure off of it being this like
really gross ugly thing that you know we
want to sort of skip now it gets a lot
harder when we are in denial when we're
in resistance or when we're not open to
letting other people in to support us
where we are just sort of living
completely out of alignment then the
Fire gets hotter and hotter right
because
the message isn't getting through
so we're just going to keep thrashing
around and so that's why I created this
book and that's why I created my
programs too it's not that you're not
going to still have to walk through the
fire but I can walk through it with you
and perhaps some of the things that I
share or some of the tools can help
lighten the load a little bit because
that's really all that we need right we
need those friends to walk with us to
not not only not feel alone in the
process but
also not feel alone in the pain of like
the magnitude of the pain because I
think what happens is that it gets
difficult for people and then they turn
away because they think they shouldn't
have to deal with something that bad
they shouldn't feel that way like oh
this must be wrong because I feel so
terrible the feeling is to go back
because it's safer and it's more
comfortable and it doesn't feel this bad
and bad must be bad what would you say
to someone that was in that space where
they feel super lost or they feel very
confused or they feel really sad like
what would you what would you say to
them in that in that moments where they
might be willing to go backwards yeah I
mean I can I can really relate to that
first of all like I really empathize
with that experience because I've been
in those states where I'm in so much
pain that I would rather go back to the
Comfort Zone even though I was miserable
there
right like I I felt that way many many
years ago when I was in my own Dark
Night of the soul that is really what
this book is a result of right is all of
that healing journey and and the stuff
that I went through to get here
and so I can remember being in so much
pain that I I thought I might not make
it through
and it's really hard to tell yourself
that this makes sense or that this is
right and you know I I don't believe
that
you know the saying like you know
everything happens for a reason and like
it's perfect like sometimes that's
really not gonna resonate when there's
like a serious tragedy or a serious loss
that you just can't make sense of right
and
you're here now like this is what's
happening you know whatever has happened
has happened and so you can't take it
back you're here and so your only choice
is to turn backward and perhaps collapse
into yourself
or to expand and to just keep going and
even if that's really slow and gentle
which it should be
you know you can just keep unfolding and
eventually you see the light it's not
this like forever dark tunnel I always
say pass pain is a passage not a prison
like you're not going to get stuck there
and I think one of the things that we
fear the most when we are in pain is
that if we let ourselves fully surrender
to this pain that we might get stuck
there or that we might get so deep that
will be locked in this depression
forever and I mean gosh I can relate to
that you know and so it's scary to let
go because we don't want to lose
ourselves but there is a bit of an ego
death happening in these moments too
right it's like can we let it go can we
just surrender to this can we let
ourselves feel it
what's behind that
and we really can shed a lot of layers
in those times of Despair and if we can
call on those few people who we love and
Trust who can hold us through and if we
can seek solace in the elements and in
nature and find ways to connect
then we can feel a little more safe in
the process
[Music]